ouch
rough night of crime fighting sir
very well you'll be happy to know i've
drawn you a bath
whenever you're ready
the deal alfred i said i drew
you a bath sir april fool's
very funny alfred i guess i'll just take
a shower
not a funny bone in his entire body
such rotter why you're the very model of
sanity
oh by the way i've pressed your tights
and put away your exploding gas balls
thank you alfred
dare we hope gotham treats you to an
early evening sir
i should be so lucky the police
emergency ban just switched on
then i'll prepare your usual breakfast
toast
coffee bandages good night alfred
am i correct in assuming metamorphic mr
hagen is back in town sir
back but not for long i'd guess it seems
that clayface is losing his integrity
i wasn't aware that he ever had any to
begin with i'm speaking in a
physiological sense alfred
based on destructive ultrasonic analysis
of the sample
the molecular bonding of his clay flesh
is breaking down
he's falling apart literally how
grotesque
tea
whatever medical process he's using to
keep himself together must cost a
fortune
which is why he's committing robberies
and that woman helping him
what's her stake in this perhaps she
enjoys mud baths
he laughs
nice footwork can you dance too
truth theorem of course the old methods
are still
often the best fight it if you like
you won't hold out for long but it might
be amusing
well anything to amuse a lady if lady is
the word i want
which i doubt oh sticks and stones
rise and shine it's a beautiful
that's odd only vampires loathe daylight
more than batman
i wonder what's keeping him there are
certain advantages to having a sturdy
crania master bruce
but then hard-headedness was always your
virtue
well i'm sure i have things to do
elsewhere
i must say you're showing a surprising
amount of compassion for that man
considering he would surely have left
you to die in his place
[Music]
with all the compartments on your belt
you'd think there'd be one for tissues
thanks
[Music]
that's good enough alfred the people i
deal with out there won't mind a little
lint
a job worth doing and all that right
master bruce
i do wish you would put on a shirt your
app to catch cold in his damn cave
oh my god
master bruce i
miss gordon i heard so you've discovered
our little secret
yes i admit it i am batman
it's all right alfred very good son
sal's having company tonight don't wait
up
meaning i trust that once you're done
with him you'll be seeing her
think you know everything about me don't
you i dive at your bottom
i bloody well ought to sir
well you're wrong
no and i suspect that's the reason for
the cover-up
i won't know for sure until i check
gothcorp's classified files
if you're going to go sneaking around a
crowded office building you'll need this
knockout gas chicken soup the only way
to fight a cold
a thrill or two along the way and with
luck
a happy ending
[Music]
how long has it been 10 years 12
all that and another lifetime she and
her father were very fond of you
i was a different person then yes
intense driven moody she'd never
recognize you now
oh dear
[Music]
get us down
son of a gun
watch your steps
i i i claim this land
for spain
roland deck it's up to something alfred
that almost goes without saying doesn't
it sir
i don't know what it is yet but i will
you don't want to be late for your eight
o'clock appointment sir
have i ever been late no sir
not once in all these years looks like a
slow night alfred
when i finish patrolling this area i'm
heading home excellent timing master
bruce
i've just taken dinner out of the oven
looks like trouble at tarnower financial
alfred i won't be home early after all
ah please don't take this the wrong way
sir but
your goose is cooked
i fixed your summer it's upstairs in the
oven what would we do without you alfred
i shudder to think closest thing hagen
had through a relationship with the
doctor
was in the film dark interlude in it he
plays eric chun
the senator who falls in love with the
plastic surgeon treating him and that's
it
his movies master bruce no time to
explain now alfred
there never is
[Music]
i've taken eight showers and i still
feel soiled
uh i've never seen so much garbage
what's wrong alfred aren't you feeling
better
what's wrong sir i destroy
a priceless ming vas and you ask me
what's wrong
don't worry about it i'll just take it
out of your salary for the next couple
of years
very well son
alfred april fools
[Music]
you